d'où vient l'expression faire l'autruche
c'est une question de maïs arrête de
faire l'autruche on a tous employer
cette expression pour encourager
quelqu'un à regarder la vérité en face
et à ne plus ignorer les problèmes elle
vient d'une croyance selon laquelle
l'autruche enfouir est sa tête dans le
sable dès qu'elle a peur sauf que c'est
complètement faux alors c'est vrai qu'on
peut parfois observer cet animal pencher
la tête au ras du sol mais rien à voir
avec la trouille lorsque l'autruche agi
ainsi c'est pour chercher à manger ou
surveiller saison à l'occasion cela peut
aussi être un moyen pour elle de se
protéger d'une tempête de sable mais en
cas d'attaqué ou de tout autre danger
elle va plutôt s'enfuir d'autant que
l'autruche est une excellente sprinteuse
capable d'atteindre les 70 km par heure
et dans le cas contraire elle est de
toute façon largement de taille à se
défendre notamment grâce à ses puissants
coups de patte ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'autruche n'est pas une poule mouillée